le street art à sa clinique ou plutôt
une ancienne clinique qui lui sert de
terrain de jeu surplus de 1000 m², une
trentaine d'artistes locaux et
internationaux redonne vie à la Friche
Saint-Gatien les fresques de cette
clinique du street art se visite dans le
noir comme a pu le constater Benjamin
va-t-elle
imaginez
déambuler dans une ancienne clinique
abandonnée et plongée dans le noir
[Musique]
c'est ce que propose la clinique du
street art dans l'ancienne clinique
Saint-Gatien un projet original créé par
plusieurs associations les visiteurs se
lancent armés d'une lampe frontale pour
découvrir le travail d'une trentaine
d'artistes de street art avec la mère
nature comme thème général chacun se
l'était approprié en seulement deux
jours à coups de pochoirs collage
sculpture et bombe de peinture pour un
résultat à la fois déroutant et
captivant je pense que c'est un thème
quai d'actualité toute façon voilà la
Mère Nature c'est aussi le rapport de
l'homme à la nature la pollution
l'environnement tous les dangers qu'on
apporte à cette terre et les artistes
n'ont pas mal répondu à ça
le concept à mi-chemin entre une
exposition d'art classique et de l'urbex
offre une expérience inédite
au milieu de tous les murs sont grassés
on est dans le noir enfin voilà il y a
l'ambiance il y a les œuvres il y a tout
qui fait qu'on est dans une atmosphère
complètement à part
curieux de découvrir cette nouvelle
exposition les visiteurs sortent avec le
sourire aux lèvres ça donne un côté bon
en plus beaucoup plus Urbex à la visite
c'est mon comment dire
comment c'est passé c'est pas banal
c'est pas commun et
s'impose à Tours parce que ça rajeunit
un petit peu l'ambiance générale en plus
de l'exposition un bar sert des produits
locaux et des DJ 7 sont organisés le
week-end la clinique du street art reste
ouverte jusqu'en septembre 2024